the first revelation spoke of Germany
spying on a fellow NATO member now
German media have named the country as
Turkey some lawmakers are astonished
that Ankara has been an official
intelligence gathering target for at
least five years SVO good Wendy wanders
figure you bought saugandh a clay on it
would be good if the government could
convincingly explain why and to what
degree Turkey has been spied on since
2009 and also how any eventual
surveillance is compatible with the
oft-quoted idea that partners don't spy
on each other in zee snitch Kagan's ipos
agents are said to have recorded at
least one phone call made by US
Secretary of State John Kerry last year
it was allegedly an accidental catch
while germany's spy service was trawling
communications in the Middle East the
same is said to have happened to Kerry's
predecessor Hillary Clinton in 2012
Berlin insists the recordings were not
deliberate but instead of being
immediately deleted the recordings were
retained and analyzed the political
damage has been done the United States
can now say that Berlin is guilty of
spine to carry is said to have enjoyed
pointing that out to his German
counterpart frank-walter steinmeier the
SEC liat lucretia FISA this may well
explain why the German government has
had so little interest in really
uncovering the NSA scandal and why
they've been so soft on the United
States they simply have had a bad
conscience I'd found Trish disqus
Berlin has not issued an official
statement